Some of these are shown in this
small example of an HL7 RIM example.
As you can see, each of these is
further specified in great detail, but
finding the explanations can be tedious.
The FHIR, F-H-I-R,
Resources site is the best
source of explanations I'm aware of,
but it is intentionally not complete.
To get a feel for this,
let's focus on the special arrangements
code in the patient encounter box.
We see here that this is
a leaf of the act box.
Meaning, it's a particular example or
instance.
I picked it because most of
the detailed names are self evident so
you can easily see the level
of detail that is specified.
D set, indicates this is
a discreet set of possible values and in
fact, although they're not shown here.
These are wheel for wheelchair.
S-T-R-E-T for stretcher.
I-N-T for interpreter.
A-T-T for attendant and
D-O-G for guide dog.
All examples of things that
would be specially arranged for
were a patient to arrive at a hospital.
Here's another detailed example where
SBADM means substance administration.
And RQO means request.
Typically part of a medication
order by a physician.